so one of your recent videos
uh you highlighted the fact that uh in
2018 we had 297 people die
from a rifle 235 was from shotguns
uh a thousand five hundred and fifteen
was from stabbing
672 was killed by hands and feet
if 297 is rifle 235 is shotgun if we
have so many more stabbings and
hands and feet why are so many folks
in dc on the left trying to
figure out ways to over regulate guns i
think you should have to do is you have
to break down
the audience so if you're talking about
just the general population of people in
the middle
who are just regular people when they're
not in politics who who want to do those
things they have a different motivation
then you have the people in dc as you
stated who have their own motivations
and i think largely the motivation is
control
and sometimes that desire for control is
they are serving as almost a proxy
um for other interests that have a
desire for
said control um because what you'll get
is you'll get a lot of politicians who
are getting money from people like
the bloombergs of the world and so forth
and so on who
they've made this issue their thing this
is their life mission so
to speak and so when they're responsible
for getting them elected in these
particular areas and these different
races
then they can't go against the person
who helped to get there in the first
place so they're going to
push for these types of laws because
they want these types of laws
but then you also get individuals in
positions of power who don't like the
idea of the common man
having access to the things that they
consider to be high-powered
because they like the idea of sitting on
this oligarchy or this throne above
everybody else because they don't see
themselves as our representatives
they see themselves as our leaders and
so you can't just have a common everyday
man
on the same level of degree of power so
to speak as you are when it comes to
the ability to protect and take life
because the most
most important thing we have the most
valuable thing we have in this world
is our life so from that perspective but
i'm somebody who sees myself as above
the common man
and i look down and i was like so let me
get this straight you mean to tell me
this little plebeian down here can own
this ar-15
and if he decides that he wants to come
i don't know take my life we're on the
same we're on the same page
no i want to relegate this person to
okay maybe maybe handguns for now but
even then i don't really like the
handgun stuff either
so i'd rather them if they're going to
protest and they're going to be angry
with this i don't want them showing up
to
showing up with with uh rifles and
handguns i want to show up with rocks
and sticks
because we have the forces necessary to
deal with that
but you're talking about a whole bunch
of people that if we do something to
them that we don't
that they don't like collectively you
mean to tell me that they can
collectively come together
take up arms and make a stand no no no
no we can't have that
and so i think that's a motivation for
some of those people who are in position
so let's look at the two different sides
i'm going to give you my view of what i
see both sides bring in our arguments
and then you give me what else you would
add to it and agree disagree whatever
makes
so one side you got the right side
republicans may say
look you can't take my gun second
amendment was there
not because of uh you know me having a
gun to go out there go
you know hunting or getting you know
food
it's more for tyranny in case the
government turns against me and i can
protect myself against them so
and the ar-15 is one of the best rifles
out there and no ar is not
called assault rifle ar stands for you
know what ar stands for
so well no it is a assault rifle no it's
not so
why do we need to do background checks
there's no need for a lot of extensive
background checks why do you need
training if somebody needs to go get a
gun today
they should be able to get it i lived in
california in texas and in florida
in texas i can go buy a gun and leave
and i wanted to be that way right
california
i had to wait i think it was four weeks
i don't know what the exact timeline was
like 30 days or something like that yeah
so that's that's this side on the other
side is
look at all these mass shootings you
know these people if they didn't have
access to the guns this would have never
happened why do you need all these guns
anyways
why do you need these semi-automatic
weapons what's the purpose of it you
make me feel scared by
all of you owning so many guns i think
it's better if we become a little bit
more responsible how hard is it to
understand this
why is it so complicated what else would
you add to the arguments of each side
i think honestly you kind of covered it
but overarching at least on the other
side is fear
it's outright fear it's it's this idea
because
most people don't really think of
themselves as being the the protector of
the defender they see themselves as the
victim
there's a potential victim so when you
only see yourselves as a potential
victim you what you think to do
is well let me disarm the potential
attacker
not let me empower myself to defend
myself against a potential attacker
and so i think for a lot of people on
the opposite side who don't want these
guns out there
they are overarchingly scared of the
potential for people to do something bad
to them
and so for me if i was going to add
anything it's just that overwhelming
fear okay so let's add those those in
there right okay so now let's go back to
guns uh if they take my guns away from
me
let's just say they do they take our
guns away from us what can they do to us
that they can't do today
so let's actually go there i'm not
telling you this yeah
please keep in mind you come to my house
i got i'm a former military
you know my background you know my
position but i'm asking let's go to
worst case scenario
let's say beto aurora runs it he's in
charge and he's the guy and he comes
and he confiscates everything away from
you forget about registering your guns
well let us register because if they
register
that's phase one then it's next one
conference i'm just telling you they're
gonna come and take everything
what's the worst thing they can do to us
after they've taken the guns
they got all the guns what's the worst
thing they can do to us i don't know ask
china
you're going that far in so you're going
yeah absolutely why
why not because at that point what's to
stop them there's nothing to stop them
everything now at this point is really
kind of a negotiation
all the things that they try to make us
do now is really kind of a negotiation
between them and us at that point
there's no negotiation
they can just do it and then if we don't
like what they do at best they
they suppress whatever half half-assed
attempt of uprising
that goes on and then keep it moving
isn't that what they did in hong kong
so i'm from iran and iran also you can't
have gun it's just the government and
you don't have the guns right they have
it you don't have the same as china same
as a lot of different places on that
side
but what is the most valuable thing you
and i have
what is the most valuable thing you and
i have if you ask the average person
what would they say
what do you think it is if we were to
say the most valuable thing we have in
america
i'm going to say in america our freedom
okay so let's just say freedom is one
which is potentially freedom of what
free enterprise freedom of assembly
freedom of religion freedom of second
amendment freedom a lot of different
freedoms right
so let's say it's freedom let's say it's
your voice
let's say it's your life okay some may
say life is at the top some may say
freedom's at the top right okay so
if they take your guns away today
is to do what to put fear into you that
they can't already do to you today
anyways
which is what i mean we got a lot of
things that we're worried about
but nowadays if the government wants to
destroy you
they can silence you because we know
these uh big social media
companies they're pretty much virtual
governments you know that i know that
and
facebook's a virtual government
twitter's a virtual government youtube's
a virtual government
if they even want to turn against one of
their own guys cuomo they can do it
they're about to destroy cuomo
they want to silence trump they can do
it if they want to find you didn't pay
five dollars in taxes and put you in
prison for six months
to defame your hurt you they can pretty
much do that if you think about it
so what is more painful that they can
already do today
that's going to change if they're able
to take our guns away from us
what's the name they do today that they
can do then
so here's the thing though everything
you everything every example that you
name is about an individual
right yes can individuals me as an
individual could they shut me down can
they do all the things that you
mentioned before
yes but but the idea about the second
amendment is about the collective
coming together and stopping and
overreaching government from a
collective standpoint
and and what the gun does and allows
what allows us to do is to serve as a
as a check against a government
potentially doing those things
because a lot of people think well you
know the government has tanks they have
missiles they have drones they have all
these things
so how do you think you're ever going to
defeat the government
and it's not necessarily about that
specifically
it's a deterrent because at the end of
the day what's the point of ruling over
people you
you've completely destroyed there's
nothing there for there's nothing left
for you to rule over
so from that perspective they understand
that like look we can only go so far and
doing certain things
whether it be whether it be like i said
pointing out some of the things that are
taking place in places like china
um from that perspective
if they try to do that from a wholesale
collective standpoint
what you're gonna get is you're gonna
get groups of people coming together to
fight back against that
now if i'm on my own i can't one-man
army to death i can't i'm going to lose
that battle
every single time but as the second
amendment state of being necessary for
the security of a free state
the right of the people to keep bear
arms shall not be infringed
based and people like to say well it's
based around the militia yeah the
militia is consistent of
each individual coming together to fight
against a potential tyrannical
government
and so yes individually they can do a
lot of things to me
but when that when what they're when
that tyranny starts to become
widespread and starts affecting enough
people having the means and the ability
with our firearms to stand up to the
government
changes the whole dynamic instantly so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye